on today's show we're going to be
talking to a gentleman whose co-worker
just got promoted and who's now his boss
and they don't get along
we're going to be talking to the mother
of an alcoholic son and how to set
boundaries during the holidays
and we're going to be talking to
somebody who is going to talk through
their childhood abuse for the very first
time
this is a heavy show so please be
careful of who's listening
and watch your own heart and mind stay
tuned
[Applause]
hey what's up i'm john and this is the
dr john deloney show
a live show with real people going
through real challenges
for you by you it's such an honor to
walk alongside folks who are struggling
with
life with their relationships with
parenting with brothers and sisters
we talk about everything on this show no
matter what's going on in your heart in
your mind and your family
you are not alone millions of people
across the country are dealing with this
too
i'm dealing with it i'm trying to figure
it out kelly zach
james everybody in the booth trying to
figure it out we're all in this together
man we're going to talk about love
loss family issues
work issues people issues
and here's the thing whatever's going on
give me a call
i'll walk through it with you we might
talk about
this i just want to tell everybody what
happened at my house last night
and just let you know man
sometimes you just stumble into
something that's awesome
last night my kids came downstairs and
they had that look in their eye like
what are y'all scheming and usually
they've come up with some song or a poem
or some
dance routine that's going to end in
them asking me for candy or ice cream
and they know i'm militant about sugar
and all that kind of stuff
but my kids came down and said dad
will you come play hide and go seek with
us and it's like four in the afternoon
here in nashville and so it's already
pitch black
and it's it feels like it's midnight
outside
and i looked at him i was working on
something for work and i said
absolutely let's do this and they both
cheered and we ran upstairs which is
just like a big open space
and we turned the lights off and my two
kids
are absolute ninja gangsters when it
comes to hide and go seek
i laughed more last night than i've
laughed in 2020
i laughed so hard that i couldn't
breathe in certain moments
my kids were laughing so hard i am the
worst at hide and go seek ever ever
my daughter is going to be an assassin
someday
but there was no screens it cost no
money
it took like an hour and a half and we
had
a blast and here's the thing you know
what our kids need more than anything
right now
our undivided attention our eye crinkles
when we look at them and they know that
we love them
our willingness to just on a whim be
silly to close the stupid laptop and go
play
they deserve our undivided attention
they deserve to know
that dad cares about him so dad's out
there
close your laptop there's gonna be
tomorrow to get more junk done
and go play hide and go seek mom's out
there
you got plans you've got ideas close the
laptop
unplug whatever it is you're doing put
the book down
and go do something silly and crazy that
costs no money and no screens but just
let your kids know
i love you and man you are gonna laugh
laugh laugh
i think i woke up with a six pack of abs
this morning just for laughing i
i super didn't wake up with a six-pack
abs i can promise you that but here's
the deal whatever's going on in your
heart in your home or your head i'm here
to stand with you to walk with you give
me a call
1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
or if you want to write your question in
contact me at johndalone.com show that's
johndaloney.com show you can fill out
the form and it'll go directly to our
inbox and we look forward to talking
with you
all right let's go straight to the
phones let's go to dean in grand
rapids michigan dean what's up my man
how we doing
doing all right dr john how are you
outstanding
so what can i do to help this morning so
my co-worker recently got promoted and
became my boss
and him and i didn't really see eye to
eye
yeah yeah oh man
and so now he's my supervisor and i get
really
nervous every time i have to meet with
him or talk with him
or when he comes to my office and so i
was wondering what can i do
to alleviate some of that anxiety
around that dude that is for real i've
experienced that
it's the worst it's the worst man
um so tell me back before your co-worker
got promoted
what was the source of the tension in
your relationship
you and i didn't really communicate at
all we kind of just
um dealt with our own
own things and our own issues um
but why would why wouldn't you
communicate with him is he annoying
is is it he or she he
okay is he annoying is does he
pick his teeth i mean what why wouldn't
you just talk to him
why wouldn't you all hang out y'all just
different people he doesn't have that
much of a personality he's
100 percent focused on work
and i like to have fun and
work is great but then i also like to
spend time with my family and go on go
on vacation and go do other things oh
you're one of those guys that likes to
have a life outside of work
how annoying dean okay
so he gets promoted how do you find out
uh through an email oh geez
okay so put everybody listening into
your head in that moment
you're just sitting there were you
expecting that you could have gotten
this promotion too
uh no it was it was kind of
it was kind of known that he would
probably get the promotion
okay but i was maybe hoping
for otherwise okay so
he gets the promotion put everybody in
your head you read this email
what are you thinking
i'm thinking i'll give it a chance but i
i don't
i don't see it going well in the future
okay at least yeah so brass tacks
is he gonna fire you do you think he's
gonna move on without you
no okay is he open to
is he open to direct conversations
uh no
so man that's challenging so if you
think there's nothing wrong
but ah okay so let's flip this around
is there nothing wrong is the issue here
you
i hope not be more specific than that
i don't think it's me i think
he just always wants to focus on work
and i want to have
i want to be able to have a life outside
of work
and so whenever we talk it's always
about work it's never
how are you doing how's your family but
is he doing things to prohibit your life
out of work
um or is he just not a conversationalist
he's not really a conversationalist and
and so
when it is always about work um i'm
unable to have
kind of a conversation about
outside of work and so i feel really
nervous
when i talk to him when i meet with him
because i know he's probably gonna
um he's gonna one have a different style
than
my previous supervisor and two
he's always gonna talk about work
he's not gonna i don't believe he's
gonna care about me as a person
okay so this this conversation shifting
a little bit
um i love the mark twain quote which is
worrying is like paying a debt you don't
owe
and it feels to me like you are worrying
about something that in the grand scheme
of things
is only affecting you as much as you're
choosing to let it affect you
so you've got a new boss that y'all
don't see eye to eye
on things meaning he talks about work
all the time you like to talk about
other things
but he's not ugly to you he's not mean
to you he's not going to fire you
he just makes you nervous because when
he interacts with you at work he wants
to talk about work and you want to talk
about other stuff
so there's something else there i
thought this is a whole different call
there's something else there with you
that feels uncomfortable
what is that and it can't it i mean it
could be but
it doesn't sound like it's just related
to my boss wants to talk about work at
work
that doesn't seem like a unrealistic
expectation
if he were to have gotten this job and
he said
i've been eyeing you man and dean you're
the worst
you knew it and your time here is short
man i'd be
stressed out if i was you i've had
bosses
that we didn't get along on a bunch of
different levels and the moment
they became a boss they let me know i've
got you in my crosshairs delaney
right one time i left i just quit i went
and worked somewhere else
once that person got promoted and that
person was so
so ridiculously rude like you know in a
comic way it was like a cartoon
um that i just smiled and was like my
felicia i'm out
right that doesn't sound like the
situation here so what is it that you're
actually worried about
i am worried about him eventually
um thinking that somebody can do a
better job than me
um there we go but he's never explicitly
said that
okay so what you are creating right now
is a self-fulfilling prophecy and
every time you're around him you're
going to be nervous and you're going to
be uncomfortable
and you're going to stutter a little bit
when you are trying to explain things
and you're going to be a little on edge
and you are going to create a world
where he recognizes that there is
tension there
and since he's the boss he's going to
find somebody with no tension
he's going to find someone who'll just
get the work done
and so what is it about your performance
that makes you feel like
somebody out there is going to do better
than you
um i
sometimes make mistakes and he's
he's a lot less forgiving than my
previous supervisor
on some of those okay and so does he
call you out on it
sure and i mean that that's his job and
that's his role
right right but um so i make mistakes at
my job too
i make mistakes all the time and
everyone i know makes mistakes
when we came in this morning the phones
weren't working right
life happens right um but we're all in
the same team and we all work for it we
all move forward together
and we all know that everybody's trying
to to do the best they can to get things
done
it seems to me that you are conjuring up
something that might happen someday and
you're choosing to live in that future
present right now
and all you're going to do is assure
that that happens
i would challenge you to set up a
private meeting with him
and tell him you are really grateful to
be working for him
and that he's got a different leadership
style and you want to make sure
that you are meeting his expectations
and then ask him are there some things i
can be doing better are there things
that
you like about my current performance
and let him just speak into you
and if he just looks at you like you've
got three heads and he's like i think
you're doing fine
then let that be what it is and then do
your best to work your butt off when
you're at work and when you're not at
work anymore check out and go home
would he be open to that conversation to
you coming in and saying
i'm really grateful that you're my new
boss i'm glad that i've got a job here
i want to make sure i'm meeting your
expectations and you're very different
than my last boss
so what are some ways i can grow and
improve what would he say if you did
that
i'm not sure so maybe i do need to have
that conversation
i think that's a worthy conversation
dean it's gonna relieve a lot of stress
and pressure on you because you're gonna
find one of two things
one you are way overblown this in your
mind
and he isn't really thinking a lot about
you he just wants to get the work done
do it right
do a good job or he's gonna fire you
and you're gonna find out much sooner
and you're gonna be able to alleviate
that worry and you're gonna be able to
start making alternative plans
something i've done the last four or
five bosses i've had
um i would ask them hey do you do
lunches do you do coffees
what are things that drive you
absolutely nuts
what are things that you really care
about i i just ask people point blank
and the last couple of bosses i had
they smiled and like no one's ever asked
me that i guess i prefer coffee over
lunch
i guess that i really get
crazy when somebody lies to me i don't
like being surprised i don't
right but it's just i'm bringing it to
them they're the boss so it's my job to
reach out there
i wish in a perfect world leaders would
reach out but they don't
right um here at ramsey they do i've had
a couple of extraordinary bosses over
the years that did but
on the whole most don't they're too busy
they're running around doing 50 other
jobs
but it sounds like dean you have
conjured up a world
where you are living in this stress that
may or may not be true
may or may not be true he might fire you
dude
i hope he doesn't but he might and the
only way you're going to know is by
going and sitting down and saying
i appreciate you and again starting with
gratitude is always the way to go
he's the boss you should be grateful
that you got a job right now there's
millions that would love to trade places
with you
so then go tell them i like that idea
man and how about this dean
go have that conversation with him and
do it in a respectful kind
way where you are legitimately trying to
learn about ways you can
help meet the expectations he's going to
have for you in this new season
and then holler back at me i want to
know how that call goes
i want to know if your concern was
overblown or if he gave you some
very clear parameters about how you have
to improve your performance
or if you got a sense a tip off oh man
my time here is short
my my worry was totally justified
and i'm going to start looking for other
work
call me back and let me know here's the
thing about anxiety
it steals your future from you and if
you're in a situation where a
simple conversation a hard conversation
looking up some data some facts and
figures will help alleviate that future
don't run from it don't hide from it
just do it
just do it and do it with a spirit of
gratitude and do it with a spirit of
inquiry not an attack not a rude way
but don't let anxiety steal your future
especially when it's
something as easy as more info
or a conversation so dean i'm i'll be
thinking about you man i want you to
circle back after you have that
conversation let me know how things are
going
my hope is the guy just has a different
style than your old boss
he's a guy that loves talking about work
when he's at work and he may surprise
you he may
like talking about family and other
things but no one's ever approached him
before
he may want to go to lunch with you man
he may want to just grab a cup of coffee
and see how things are going or he may
not
he may be one of those weird guys that
when they go to work they just want to
work
and god bless those folks man those are
awesome all right uh thank you so much
for that call let's go to angela
in seattle angela what's going on
good morning john uh my question
is how best to handle
alcohol in the house and personal
consumption
when i've got a relative of my son who
is an alcoholic coming
or to visit for a whole week that's a
great question
so tell me about your son uh he's
uh 29 he well he tells me we have a good
relationship we talk every sunday
he tells me he's an alcoholic he knows
he's an alcoholic and he's not willing
to do
anything about it um i enabled him for
way too many years
and the path of least resistance was
then to move in with his alcoholic
father my ex-husband
he's a he's a good kid and he's not
figured out
what he needs to do with his life yet
and he's kind of just
i'm waiting for him to wake up but it
hasn't happened yet but i love him and
he's coming for a week and i want to see
him
and i want to make sure that we have a
great time
and i've always got a few bottles of
liquor here in the house but
i feel like while he's here i we
probably should put them away
and not drink ourselves yeah so the way
you've painted that picture
the only responsible caring thing to do
in that set of circumstances
is to get every shred of alcohol out of
your house and to let him know before he
comes
that there will be knock on the house
and it won't be welcome in your house
yeah and anything short of that is you
putting him in a position to fail
yeah you know we're we live smack in the
middle of a downtown
area where he can walk to a bar in three
minutes
right here's here's the other another
thing
you know as well as i do if he goes out
to a bar
within if you know and i don't even know
if they're allowed to go to bars in
seattle right now if he does go to a bar
and gets all tanked up and then comes
back to your house
you're not going to have a good week
because that'll burn that night and
you'll be stressing
it'll burn all the next day because
he'll be hungover and not feeling well
you'll feel ashamed he'll feel ashamed
there'll be the whole mess
and so setting some boundaries now that
not only includes you letting him know
i'm getting rid of all the alcohol out
of the house we're going to have an
alcohol-free week
but also you cannot come to my house
drunk
yeah yeah the good news is washington
state is
the bars are going to be closed that's
right
through uh well into december so
that's actually i had i hadn't thought
about that um
so can he can he go a week without
drinking
uh i i don't know if he's a true
alcoholic he might not be able to and so
a whole week at your house may be a long
time
and as much as you want him there you
have to do the hard hard work
of letting that fantasy of your little
boy coming for a week and having a
lovely
remember the times thanksgiving that's
not gonna happen
if he is a true functioning alcoholic
there's gonna be some challenges
that week right and i don't want you to
set
yourself up for heartbreak or set him up
for failure
right and so maybe it's a three-day trip
or maybe it's a
48-hour trip yeah
yeah i have no idea of knowing how it
might go sideways but i hear you what
does
are you are you remarried yes
what does your husband think about him
coming to visit oh
he's fine with that he's as my husband
always says
we're rooting for him we want him to
succeed you know we
um and we talked about this and we we
definitely both agree not having alcohol
in the house is the right thing to do
and not drinking that week ourselves is
the right thing to do
because we do love him and my my
new husband loves him i mean he's
you know he's we want to help him so we
don't want to enable him
there you go and here's the thing he's
he's blessed to have somebody like you
that cares about him
and sounds like your new husband's a
saint too good for him
i've met a number of new husbands second
husbands over the years that don't want
anything to do with their spouses adult
kids and so good for him
and here's what i think is going to make
the whole week
much better and that is you s sitting
down
and writing these out for yourself and
then calling your son
and then just letting your son know i
want to set up
the best week possible for all of us
you tell me all the time you're an
alcoholic i want to know
how long you can go without drinking
because i'm going to take the alcohol
out of the house i want us to have a fun
connected sober time and be ready
angela for him to blow his top and to
throw a temper tantrum and be mad and
say you're not getting rid of all the
alcohol it's going to be a terrible
thanksgiving or i don't want you to have
to do all that
he might do that and if he does he does
yep
hopefully he doesn't hopefully he says
wow that's awesome my parents love me
and they care about me
and you know that's a long stretch for a
true alcoholic
and maybe he's just running his mouth a
little bit about being an alcoholic he
may be
he likes to drink he likes to drink with
his old man um but he
he may be just fine going a week right
but i think the
the true adult integrous thing to do
is to call him on the front end and set
up the ground rules whatever they may be
and letting him know hey i'm taking all
the booze out of the house
yeah he's been pretty pretty good at
understanding um
i you know have not given him any money
for
almost a year now i'm not enabling him
like i was and he
he actually accepts that and we have
a good relationship so it's awesome i
feel like he'll
understand why i'm doing it because i i
do use uh i love you too much
to it's it's too painful for me i'm not
the adult child of an alcoholic i had an
alcoholic ex-husband
now i have an alcoholic son that's right
i know i can be over sensitive
and i need to watch myself about setting
boundaries in a kind of
organized non-emotional way there you go
and let's
understood it let your new husband let
him know that this is hard for you
i know you already have but let him know
hey i'm going to set some boundaries
down
and people who are true addicts they
will hear you
intellectually but emotionally they will
they will
say things to you and they will fight
you and they will kick you
not not physically but they will fight
and kick and scream
because their their inner child is
hurting out it's hurting right it's
yelling yeah
so set those boundaries feel good about
them
understand that you're caring about him
but do the next
right hard thing which is to let him
know ahead of time
and understand that anytime you set up a
boundary there is a chance
that other people respond poorly to that
boundary and he may throw a temper
tantrum and not come
he may say if you're going to do all
this then i'm just going to stay here
with that
and your whole week is going to be blown
and you're going to call and you're
going to say deloney you
told me to call him and i wish i hadn't
of because this sucks
and he didn't show up and i'm gonna be
sad with you
but it still would be the right thing to
do
letting him know hey you can't come to
my house drunk if you leave my
house if you sneak booze into my house
i'm going to ask you to leave we're
going to have an alcohol-free week i
want to set us all up to be successful
and if you can't go that long i totally
understand i love you
let's only let's only spend three or
four days together
good for you angela i appreciate you
trying no matter how old your son gets
you know he's almost 30 you're still
trying to figure out ways to love him
you're still trying to figure out ways
to no longer empower them good for you
and you also recognize the one
heartbreaking thing about
addiction and loved ones is that they
have to choose we can't do it for them
we can't make other people get well and
that
sucks so it makes us feel powerless
right
but thank you so much angela for the
call let me know how it goes i want to
know how the thanksgiving holiday goes
um man we will be rooting for you
all right i want to talk real quick
about something that's making its way
around the interwebs you've probably
heard of it it's called
toxic positivity toxic positivity is an
unrealistic dismissive overly optimistic
view of the world and here's the thing i
am a to the death
optimist i was raised and trained by
a gentleman named michael shonrock who
was the original optimist that i'd ever
met
and he he gave me so many
cool uh tips and ideas and perspectives
on how to see the world
in a more optimistic way
but there's a difference between
optimism and toxic positivity
toxic positivity tries to just move away
the ugliness and the heaviness of life
with
nah bruh it's going to be cool and good
vibes in these nonsensical
pinteresty instagrammy empty mantras
right
and toxic positivity is not the same as
positive psychology
positive psychology is focused on
resilience controlling your mindset
which is
controlling the things you can control
and letting the other stuff go
right always looking towards ways you
can
improve your situation it's about
resilience
it's not about it's all good toxic
positivity creates a false view of the
world it's all rainbows and butterflies
and puppies and unicorns it's just
immature
quite honestly if you want to live an
authentic life and achieve
anything worthwhile right
anything you got to kill the fantasy
dr andrew young used to tell us all the
time during crisis response
facts are your friends when things are
good
and when things are bad facts are your
friends
right if your world's on fire
ao2020 acknowledge it
acknowledge it because here's the thing
toxic positivity
hurts people who are experiencing real
difficulty when you say things like
dude just look for the silver lining or
it could be worse
or come on man stop being so negative or
suck it up yo
man don't say those things to friends
who are going through hard things
instead be present listen and just
acknowledge the difficulty they're
facing
when you when you suppress
feelings man when you shove them down
another word for suppress is depressed
right another word for suppress is
depress
don't depress yourself don't depress
your emotions don't depress the people
around you
if people are driving you crazy with
their negativity step away
or ask for permission do i have
permission to give my insight here
hey are you asking me for my thoughts on
this situation because there's another
way we could look at it
and that's different than hey just look
for the silver lining yo
right toxic positivity is naive and
destructive
may we all listen well to those who are
suffering and be people of realistic
courage in the world
is corona wreaking havoc yep
is the economic fallout going to be
devastating yep
does the u.s owe 25 trillion dollars now
we're just mailing people checks for
crying out loud
is that going to serve us well holy
smokes man
no no
is there fighting going on all over the
world yep is our country
incredibly divided yep
are neighbors hating neighbors yep
is that a reason to not be optimistic no
it's not
it just means i got my work cut out for
me that means you've got your work cut
out for you
that means that we all have to lean in
this together but denying it pretending
it's not real
is foolish and it hurts people so let's
do away with toxic positivity let's do
away with
living by the instagram quote or the
pinterest quote
or the little wooden sign we hang in our
in our on the new ship lap in our new
kitchens right
and let's get to the hard gritty work of
being actual optimist of actually
working hard to change our situations
for the better
being resilient honoring people and
sometimes just sitting with people and
saying thanks for sharing
sucks
thanks for sharing i'll be praying for
you
how can i help right all right so let's
go back to the phones let's take one
more let's go to ken
in green bay wisconsin what's up ken
good morning
hey dr d good to talk to you today
youtube brother how are we doing
i'm doing all right how are you doing
all right myself so how can i help ma'am
so i'm 29 years old um i've kept
quite a dark secret all these years um
and you're honestly the
first this is the first time i've really
ever even spoke of this
so um i've seen counselors and
therapists
not too many over the years but in my in
my 20s i've seen a couple
and i still never had the courage to
really talk of it um
so now i've just it's been eaten at me
all these years and i've just decided
that
because my life is where it's at right
now and some of the habits and the
problems i face day to day i feel like
because of this
problem i face as a child that it might
have something to do with it so
basically what happened hey uh but hold
on hold on before you
before you tell me what you're about to
tell me that's quite the setup here
so why me
why did you choose to whatever's been
hanging on for 30 years now three
decades
why now why me well because
you know i've really enjoyed seeing you
on dave ramsey's show i really
taking a liking to the things that you
have to say to callers
and i like your insight and i feel like
saying this over the phone
and not face to face to somebody i don't
know at all
was a little bit easier okay all right
well i
don't know where you're about to head
with this but i appreciate your trust
and
go for it so so tell me what you've been
sitting on
so basically when i was about four or
five years old
um i was sexually molested by my older
brother for quite some time
oh man i'm so sorry thanks
and it just it was so weird i
remember it so vividly but at the same
time it's so foggy
um i don't know if my family
really knows about it i think they do
um i have four older brothers i'm the
youngest of five boys
and uh i just i remember it happening
over and over while i shared a room with
my older brother and i don't know
why we shared a room i don't i don't
understand it because we
were he's the second oldest and i'm the
youngest so i don't really know how that
worked out or whatever but i do recall
it just ending one day it just ended
what was the age difference between you
and your brother
um so he is
seven and a half years older than me
okay hmm
so nothing too significant but that's a
lot that's a whole whole lot
um especially if you're talking about
three four and five
and 10 11 and 12. that's a big big gap
what makes you think that folks in your
family knew or know about this
um because i just remember i remember
ending abruptly one day um
and i and i have this vision i'm not
sure if it's a dream of this vision but
i remember
my mom yelling at my older brother at
one moment because i feel like maybe
another brother of mine
kind of found out or saw what was
possibly going on and then told my mom
but i never
spoke to my mom about it i never spoke
to anybody about it
and my mom has since passed away and
i i get really upset that i never talked
to her about it and i don't want to
bring it up to anybody now
especially my brother because of how
awkward it may be
or how you know i feel like he's kept us
inside too
you know so so as we dig into this
i need you to remember one key important
thing
somebody took something from you
and from this point forward you are in
control of the narrative
you are in control of the way this plays
out
okay and
i want you to know that it's noble and
kind to think about his
his feelings it's noble and kind for you
to think about
what he might be going through but the
reality is
people who suffer abuse at the hands of
loved ones
often spend their life trying to make
sure everybody else is okay
yeah and the one person they don't make
sure is okay is them
and so i'm giving you permission you
don't need my permission but i'm giving
it to you anyway
that it's time for you to start caring
for you
okay okay i mean it sounds like over the
years you've dabbled in
talking to professionals you've hemmed
and hauled around it
because you know you weren't well you
knew something was gone on your inside
and um now it's time to
decide whether you know what the way
things are just having said it out loud
on the radio in front of millions of
people
that's out there i feel better now or
you're gonna go be about healing
and that may or may not end up in
sitting down and talking with your
brother about what happened
so circling back
now that you know like you're in control
you've said it out loud
there's several traumas here one is yeah
being sexually abused by your
someone who loves you your older brother
that's big
number two almost as bad if not worse
because again your brother's 11 your
brother's 12 your brother's
you know 13 during this stuff not
letting him off the hook but he also is
a child
right right as bad
if not worse is the thought that my
adult mom
knew this was happening and didn't do
anything
or my adult mom did know this was
happening she put a stop to it but never
stopped to ask me if i was okay
right and ken that's not okay
that that happened to you that's wrong
and that sucks
totally and so you've said it out loud
and i know you've i'm just assuming here
you have fantasized about that
conversation with your mom
you fantasized that conversation about
your brothers with your brothers
you fantasized about having a
conversation with the actual brother who
hurt you
so i ask you this what do you want to do
um well getting the courage to speak to
you today about this was was difficult
enough but i do feel like a weight has
fallen off my shoulders
um do you feel i really do you feel
different than before you said that out
loud
yeah describe that to people listening
because there are millions of people
who have suffered things that can't
bring themselves to say it out loud
and people don't realize what it feels
like to just set that cinder block
down for a second yeah
i mean i really feel like i was just
carrying a backpack full of cinder
blocks all these years i really do and
it's just
it feels really good to just say it out
loud i've kept this secret suppressed
for all these years my entire life
essentially
yeah and just saying it it makes me feel
like a whole different person
well i appreciate your your trust here
man i appreciate your bravery
and so going back what do you want to do
now
um well i haven't given it a whole lot
of thought because i never thought i'd
really get the courage to tell you
yeah but i do i do feel like i want to
discuss this with with at least my other
brothers
first before i approached the brother
that did this to me
because i'm a little closer to my other
brothers than i am him
but i i really don't know i i really
don't want to
my dad's still around and alive but i
really don't want to talk to him about
it we're not very close anyway but i
would like to approach my other brothers
and just see if it's something that they
were ever aware of or
you know but i really don't want to
drive a wedge between
my brother and the other ones out you
know either
and so a couple of things here number
one you're not driving a wedge
that wedge was driven by somebody else
okay and it's not your responsibility to
continue to make sure your other
brother's okay
it is important to remember that he was
a child too
right right but the wedge has been
driven
okay i want to ask you what do you want
to accomplish by having the conversation
and there's not a right or wrong answer
to this
but do you want ultimately him to say he
was sorry
do you want him ultimately to
acknowledge that he hurt you and that he
wished he hadn't
what are you hoping to get to do you
want to see him go to jail
what do you what do you want to see
happen
i don't want anything negative to happen
to him and i certainly don't
expect an apology because i realize he
was a child as well
i guess my main motivator would be to to
figure out if this was possibly
or excuse me if this event that happened
had any bearing on the way i am today as
far as
my own issues you know my own sexual
problems that i may face today with
with my own self you know did that event
have any
any cause on this the way i am
so what sexual problems do you have now
well
growing up i always had this thought of
teeter-tottering on whether or not i was
gay right you know i never i never felt
the urge per se but i always thought
maybe i was
yep um i've never never done anything
physical with another man but i've
always had that thought like maybe i
am and i've always had girlfriends i
have a girlfriend now
and uh you know i always thought what if
i'm bisexual what is this what if that
because
because of this event because it screwed
up my whole head yeah
um you know i have porn i have porn
addiction pornography i watch
often um you know i i somewhat abuse
alcohol
not terribly but i somewhat abuse it
because i have an addictive personality
yeah so i just wonder if these issues
are because of this
i i think it's a futile exercise to look
for
a particular pinpoint cause of
x and y and z i also think the answer to
all those questions
is going to be in some shape form or
fashion yes
one of the most damning things about
sexual abuse about abuse of any kind is
it makes you start doubting yourself it
plants all kinds of different questions
and seeds in your heart and mind
that wouldn't have been there in the
first place
and it fractures
connection because it weaponizes
relationships right
your body begins to associate closeness
in love with hurt and the only thing
that keeps us well
is relationships that's it
and that's the demon that's the forest
fire that will rage through family
trees for years is disconnection
that makes us anxious and it makes us
depressed and it makes us
look to shut off those alarms with
varying sorts of addiction and you just
name several of them right
it makes us not trust ourselves and
spend our whole lives performing to make
sure everyone around us is okay
and it's exhausting right oh big time
yeah and so
here's you can take this for what it is
you
have permission to do whatever you want
to do in this situation
okay
before you go meet with your other
brothers
i would recommend sitting down with a
with a counselor that you trust and
being honest for the first time
being absolutely honest
i would have i want you to to mention to
that counselor
your plan to go to your other brothers
before your your
the offending brother
without knowing more about your family
dynamics and again we only have 10
minutes or 15 minutes here on the radio
i feel like going directly to that
brother after
you've got some healing and some um some
very specific questions to ask
that you can work through with a trauma
counselor
and again this isn't a lifetime event i
think you can go meet with somebody
um and get to some specif
i think you can meet with somebody and
get to some specific
questions and goals very quickly you're
a real articulate guy you've obviously
thought through this for a long long
time
but i want you to recognize what's about
to happen to you okay
you put this out there you've said it
now
once you take the lid off this thing
you're going to be filled with rage
that you've been keeping down for a long
long time
you're gonna be feel and you're gonna
have rage and it's gonna spew at
everybody okay you are going to
continue to look at every single
disagreement in your life
and want to blame and push and point
some of that will be accurate some of it
won't
and you're going to feel things that you
haven't ever felt because they've been
buried underneath this deal
okay that's why it's real important to
have somebody to walk with you during
this next season
okay and it's not a life again it's not
a lifetime of
you're gonna be in therapy for the rest
of your life that doesn't mean that
you're not gonna be able to heal
relationships
but it does mean that by taking the
cover off this thing you're gonna have
to deal with some stuff you haven't
dealt with
you're probably gonna have some regrets
that you've made in your life that
you're gonna have to work back through
and forgive yourself for
and you might need to end up calling
your girlfriend and saying i'm sorry
about some things
letting her in on this conversation
right
right but at some point
sitting down with your offending brother
if he'll have the conversation
when you're ready to rock and roll that
may be real healing for you
and after meeting with a counselor and
talking through specifically what
happened
going through a trauma narrative
learning some some
coping skills that don't involve
pornography that don't involve alcohol
that don't involve
yelling and flying off the handle or
whatever other challenges you experience
you may realize dude i'm not gonna have
a conversation with him there's no need
to
there's no need to right i'm not gonna
get the closure i was looking for i'm
not gonna get the apology that i
desperately want or maybe you will
right right but
that's true but i want you to keep in
mind you're in control of
how this plays out but i also want you
to keep in mind
that now that you've said it out loud
there's going to be some
some instant release some instant
like you said bricks down you're going
to put those cinder blocks on the ground
and now the real work is gonna start
because now you've acknowledged it and i
want you to
be a good steward of you ken i want you
to love my buddy ken
for the first time and i want you to
start by asking somebody who's a
professional to walk alongside you and
you got to be honest with them
i will certainly do that okay
i'm i really appreciate it i'm proud of
the call i'm proud of your bravery
and if you were just walking out to take
the trash out tonight and you burst out
into tears i want you to know that's
okay
and if your girlfriend calls tonight and
says hey i can't
i can't get together tonight let's do it
tomorrow and you just
fill rage race through your body i want
you to know that's okay
it's how you handle it on the back end
that's that's gonna determine character
right
but now you're just taking step one of a
long healing process
okay okay as you make your way through
this
i want you to reach out to me ken i want
to know how the conversation with a
counselor goes
i want to know a couple of like a month
from now a couple weeks from now
as you begin to wrestle with this and
you start to imagine
sitting down at a table in your living
room with your brother
what that conversation will be like
and let's keep talking let's keep
talking because i want to hear how this
thing plays out
i want to honor your bravery brother and
man i'm proud of you for saying it out
loud
i'm proud of you for taking that cinder
block out of your backpack that somebody
else put in there
and just setting it down setting it down
not carrying it anymore
my hope is that the spring returns to
your step a spring that you may have
never known ken
and you're able to connect with your
girlfriend you're able to
stop having intimacy with
fantasies with people on a computer and
you're able to have intimacy with real
people in real life
and that's gonna be a process you're
gonna have to learn how to do that
you're gonna be able to quit drinking
when you get scared quit drinking when
you feel alone
you quit drinking when you feel shame
and be able to lean into real people
and you're gonna have to learn how to do
that because that was taken from you at
a young age
and i hope that you get to a place of
forgiveness
and that's the last final brick to set
down
but the healing starts today my brother
and i'm proud of you ken i'm proud of
you
we'll be thinking about you we'll be
praying for you and your family my
friend
so as we wrap up this show want to lean
into a great song
written by stephen jenkins
it's off the self-titled album
third eye blind called motorcycle
drive-by
stephen writes summertime and the wind
is blowing outside and lower chelsea and
i don't know what i'm doing in the city
and the sun is always in my eyes and it
crashes through the windows and i'm
sleeping on the couch when i came to
visit you
that's when i knew that i could never
have you and i knew that before you did
still i'm the one who's stupid and
there's this
burning like there's always been
and i've never been so alone
and i've never been so alive and visions
of you
on a motorcycle drive by the cigarette
ash flies in your eyes and you don't
mind and you smile
and say the world doesn't fit with you i
don't believe you you're so serene
just careening through the universe your
axis on a tilt
you're guiltless and free i hope you
take a piece of me with you
and there's things i'd like to do that
you don't believe in
and i would like to build something but
you'll never see it happen
and there's this burning like there's
always been
and i've never been so alone and i've
never been so alive
i've never been so alone and i've
never been so alive this has been
the dr john deloney show